welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about the old
hunkalicious gods that make you tweet
gilf
is that g for grandpa or god we'll never
tell
my name is mt and i'm here today with
the man the myth the legend himself
philip molina what's going on homie
i gilf uh
man i didn't i just imagined like what
it would take to like stay fit and
active enough so that when i am a
grandpa someday to still be a guilt
right that i have a new goal in life hey
guess where i am where you at bro like i
see your background like what's going on
there bro i'm at for the first time ever
i'm at official epic hero shop
headquarters in austin texas we're here
for uh rtx uh part of a crew but also
this is a company that that i started
with with uh some other partners and we
make all of the we made that shirt that
you're wearing yes
that's where this was the place that
does it
yes exactly come back home baby
but i love the background to see some of
our merch back there i dig it and dig it
a lot yeah yeah there's some also we're
starting to to help other people out
with their merch too um so some of it is
not ours but yeah
yeah it's very exciting though i would i
took a tour of a warehouse
it blew my mind i was like i never
thought i'd be in a
box this big i've made it
was not air-conditioned and the the the
children workers were very upset
oh my goodness uh
disclosure there's not actually children
workers but maybe all uh maybe one day
you don't get to make that disclosure
you didn't you you weren't there
it's true i didn't ask
i'll say they're not allowed to bring
ideas into work because we don't want to
know
that's our number one
rule oh my god do you have a birth
certificate that's what we need to know
that's it oh
yeah all right what's our big question
for today empty
is philip employing slave labor
uh what are we talking about today well
hey this is fun by the way i don't think
i've ever done this show with you i
haven't done it in a super long time
yeah man like super super fun i'm glad
to do it man oh so i'll throw out there
i'm sorry real quick this is the first
red bull i've had in like two years
let's see what happens dang you must
have a busy day today man yeah you broke
your your red bull um
what do you call it
sobriety
i'm back on the bull but with thor love
and thunder having been released just
the other day we are getting introduced
to the character of zeus in the mcu and
in the comics zeus is an immensely
powerful god who easily took down the
incredible hulk among many others but
with odin already in the mcu it got us
thinking how do zeus's power stack up to
odin's and which leads us to this week's
big question who is the most powerful
god odin or zeus do you know that i came
up with this question and i've been
screaming it in like the hallways
forever i just keep saying like who is
more powerful oh dinner zoos and i had
no one was listening to me like i was
just like a crazy old man to be fair i
was i was in a hospital hallway and not
our workplace
but
either way i really yeah i really want
to know the answer to this i also know
that we were talking about this we can't
do it based on the movies because we
don't we haven't seen the movie yet and
we don't know how powerful zeus is gonna
be in the movie so this part at least i
mean we know what odin's done in the mcu
but we're gonna have to do this based on
what zeus has done in the comics which
honestly is he's pretty op in the comics
so it's gonna be a very interesting
fight like he can't die right like that
like it's gonna just be very interesting
super interesting for sure but yeah and
so as we know zeus and odin are two of
the most powerful gods in the universe
and rulers of their respective kingdoms
zeus of olympus and odin of asgard
they both are sky fathers leaders of the
gods who have insane levels of power and
although their kingdoms have gone to war
with each other before they generally
live peacefully under a treaty that the
two rulers signed and odin and zeus have
even fought alongside each other many
times before but before
whoops
no you can't retake that i'm not gonna
let you retake that before is the best
thing you've ever said
totally unexpected hello i'm before
before
but i feel like chris chris hemsworth
should call himself yeah the
before
but yes um and while they have a lot in
common they definitely have their
differences too so let's take a look at
each one individually before we pit them
against one another starting with zeus
yeah i want to start with zeus because
i'm obsessed with uh greek mythology
right like i have this whole theory
about like which superheroes are like
actually based on just greek characters
like you know batman is really just
odysseus if you like breaking down
enough but anyway zeus is just zeus
and he's just the most like powerful
insane being
literally the god of heaven sky and the
weather which is like kind of like a
little like i wish it was like
like heaven and hell and but they have
different people are gods of hell so
the weather but he's thousands and
thousands of years old uh he's
definitely the strongest olympian but
specifically of the gods of olympus uh
and olympians in general aren't
technically immortal they're nearly
immortal
zeus has some exceptions it seems that
zeus is most likely completely immortal
and just cannot die but zeus and the
other olympians have one kind of um
achilles heel if we're saying the greek
stuff uh is that they
were they have to consume ambrosia in
order to remain immortal
and to keep their powers uh kind of like
it's their juice basically it's their
mark maguire you know 85 home runs or
whatever
is there their ambrosia
uh
but
i've always loved that because i used to
they the first time i've ever heard the
phrase ambrosia i heard it's it
described like it was a teacher and they
wrote like ambrosia the nectar of the
gods and it was just like that's the
sexiest damn liquid like i've ever heard
of in my entire entire life
yeah hell yeah
you want some nectar of the gods
it's like that sunny d commercial what
we got oh we got some uh grape juice so
the purple scent
nectar of the gods yeah
give me some more of that nectar of the
gods legitimately i used to think i used
to think uh what so that's what i would
call orange juice because orange juice
is so expensive and i was so poor
growing up that it'd be like a glass of
ambrosia and then we would like sip a
little bit and pass it around or
whatever
with pulp
we must drink
this is tronya
i hope you relish it as much as i but
you know more about uh uh zeus's body
than i do oh you've been doing your
homework let me tell you what zeus's
physical being is quite insane because
zeus can lift 90 tons 90 times without
using his other powers
remind me how many tons is an elephant
two
i think so i don't know
um somebody in this in the comments is
already mad that i brought elephants at
all but i'll say i think it's like two
tons or so so 45 elephants without using
his other powers damn damn that's a
strong dude he has a planet fitness
membership he has a
but his skin his muscle and bone tissue
is three times denser than humans and he
has incredible speed stamina agility and
reflexes i gotta i gotta say
three times denser skin than things is
like maybe his least impressive stat
like
like skin's pretty stable even like i
feel like like i was staying on the
elephants or like a rhino that's gotta
be like 20 times denser so he's like oh
yeah his skin isn't so hot his skin's
like
an elephant would probably withstand a
blade better than zeus probably um which
is kind of crazy what a [ __ ] is that
the point of this episode
but no he has he has so it's his powers
that protect him right right right and
he has a superhuman invulnerability that
keeps him safe from injury in extreme
temperatures and if he does get injured
no problem because he can also
regeneratively heal his limbs and organs
not to mention he can survive without
oxygen water or food and is immune to
all terrestrial diseases it's pretty
dope terrestrial diseases space syphilis
right
together gets them every time it's it's
a [ __ ] yeah this space herb that zeus
gets around if you saw that trailer he
gets around he gets a lot of legs
absolutely yeah
yeah well it's because yeah his power is
a seduction space herpes
remember i said earlier he's the god of
the sky and of the weather that actually
is like he controls climate but so
climate change is thanks to
zeus that's where we get that yeah
that's where we get the famous the
shooting the lightning like um you know
like in flash whatever uh the character
of zoom can wield lightning but like
charging him and throwing it him it's
direct lightning because he it's a
weather uh phenomenon that he's able to
control he can also send his energy
and his image and his voice to earth
from olympus so like the voice of god
the image of god and the energy of god
which is one of the most um like aligned
with like christian god kind of powers
that he has like christian god doesn't
throw lightning bolts very often
but that idea of like speaking to you
from the beyond burning bush that's what
happens when you got space herb all
right then
[Applause]
he can take away uh and restore other
olympians powers uh which is just like a
dick move right because he like
he's the father of many of them he's
just like taking away their car keys to
their powers he also has this weird
thing which i think like like he's so op
that it's so weird that he needs this
but he can temporarily if he really
needs to just be stronger that's one of
his powers he can temporarily increase
his physical strength where he's just
like why not always be that level you're
like you're just picking it arbitrarily
like you need to pick up 46 elephants
he's like oh god it's about me with like
all the groceries i'm doing this in one
trip from the car no matter what
yeah he can also change his um size and
appearance and that's very much like an
old greek thing where just like the gods
changing their appearances just like
mess with people it's our version of
undercover boss is what we
he can also open portals um and open and
close portals there's a couple things
that what he uh he has oh uh he can give
powers like the same way with the
olympians he can actually give powers to
humans and like dead humans even and
just
bring them to life for a while give them
some powers um which is honestly like
like that's a cool thing that i wish
made into christian cod mythology or
whatever it's just like you know if
you're if you pray really hard for
powers god will just be like yeah you
deserve it uh you see dead people little
kid that would be i feel like the bible
be a lot more entertaining if they had
superheroes sorry yeah bible
uh the kind of it kind of dude jesus is
a
superhero the best superhero of all yeah
he has one power that i think is like
cheating where like because he doesn't
use it very often but i think it's
because like even like i don't know the
creators are just like it's a little too
much he can see the future he can gaze
into the future like raven samoa
he just chooses like not to do that
yeah he does it the way that doctor
strange did it with the 14 million
realities where he can actually like see
different paths into the future but like
that's the entirety of other characters
entire thing that made like uh teresias
like oh the great why ceresis you can
see into the future zeus is all
knowing like all powerful and you can
kind of see in the future but like
doesn't like to do it like so obviously
this guy is
like too powerful and yet somehow
odin is supposedly kind of supposed to
be a match to him theoretically we know
thor's not but odin might be so i know
that's part that you you research for
this question yes now it is time
to show you what odin can do what can
odin do with that one eye let's find out
let's look at odin because like zeus
odin has superhuman speed agility
reflexes stamina durability and strength
and in odin's prime he could match
zeus's 90 ton lift strength and even
around his death he could even lift like
around 60 tons so like
from from his prime to his old age it's
like only a 30 ton loss of strength
that's still pretty good who checked
that who was like hey this guy's on his
deathbed and it's like see how much he
can still lift
i can see his doctor i want to do that
yeah yeah lift this freaking huge
barbell of
i'm
literally dying it's like yeah but it's
pretty cool pretty cool way to go
we got to get this data before you go i
mean i don't know there's going to be a
big question episode about it
one of two mortals will do do a big
question about your body they have to
know but yes odin's body tissue is also
three times denser than humans like like
just like zeus's which is also very
weird how are they measuring this uh
it's very odd like you got thick skin
like that just means they have elbow
skin all over their body
that's all that means it's a little
thicker
the bottom of your foot like that's
that's our entire body
that's what it is
now i want to feel his skin just to be
grossed out of the elbows
only elbows
just like a shell of skin
oh my god this goes
not impressed
okay all right buddy
[Laughter]
i just i lose my computer sometimes all
right here we go
i love it i love it we're keeping all
this in sorry
odin's body tissue is also three times
denser than humans and he shares the
same regenerative healing power and he's
also immune to all terrestrial diseases
as well which is really great if you're
a god you don't want to get you know
regular stupid diseases like covet 19
you ever hear about that
regular herpes and regular rubies
were
somehow worse than space herpes um in
god
but while odin has an extremely long
life expectancy and ages extremely
slowly he's not immortal like zeus's
speaking of life expectancy odin is
older than the sun moon and earth and
existed in a time before time which
makes him billions of years old
so does that so odin is older than zeus
right zeus i know is thousands of years
old but the sun is like at least three
thousand years old right right at least
um that's what they know
who really knows well you got to cut it
in half and count the rings
count the reasons to sound like a tree
that's how you find out if uh that's how
we find out how old our uh workers in
the warehouse are
i promise we don't have workers in the
warehouse people but um well that's why
you shouldn't ask them their age because
that's how we have to find out so just
assume they're of age
or it's on you we assume they're all 18
when they grab the application but phil
tell me about odin's powers
well i know that odin's powers and look
this up are like a lot of them are super
similar um but
they're like because we're based on the
comics he has like specific instances of
things that he did was like that's a
power that's a crazy power like he
transported the entire human race to an
alternate dimension he just like scooped
us up and moved us which is
close to what a lot of people thought
that the snap was like right they
thought like in the blip maybe everyone
got moved to the soul stone which i
don't know that seems inaccurate but
either way like that's just a thing that
odin can do with the odin force i guess
he um this is a really funny one he can
cast uh his enemies into space by just
like thinking about it
like
like just chilling on the toilet and
just like
so many of my problems would be solved
with this power yeah yeah
i just like like just like you're
looking at a window like over uh boston
where you you know you had a bad day and
you're seeing people just shoot off in
the space just like i like to think that
he shoots them out of their underwear
a little a little too fast
you flick too hard just like that for us
i like the idea of left behind uh
because the clothes stayed and left
behind but it's just the underwear
that's just the underwear
and the person like just goes 25 feet to
the right
anyway
yeah slightly raptured the empty story
it can cast on music space he can also
okay this is like his version of another
op thing he can
like reading minds isn't enough so he
can read minds of people or beings in
other dimensions he like knows what
they're thinking which is like i used to
think
invasive thoughts and then i would be
like god if you're listening
here's something gross and you're the
one choosing to listen to it so aren't
you the pervert
not me
it's that on a multiversal scale
he can do uh just like force blasting
kind of stuff like kind of like the
lightning bolt sort of it's just like
four stuff um there's there's things
where you can manipulate matter but it's
like that that power is so unregulated
in america that we don't know exactly
what the limits are to it just like what
he can manipulate he can do he can make
like for instance in that energy
projection you can also make force
fields uh
to the extent like not even just like
little cute bubbles he can actually
bubble an entire city and like create
like a shield around it um
which he just chooses not to do i guess
sometimes he can also do that thing
where he changes sizes which is just
like a popular thing that people like to
do sometimes he does not need a
bluetooth yeah
he can mr fantastic himself into being a
wonderful lover uh he uh speaking of
being endowed he can endow people with
powers
just like
zeus can um he can also
uh
oh he he did this like weird thing that
i don't fully understand in the comics
he can take like the entire population
of a planet and just like smoosh it
into one beam
and be like look i made this and it's
like
but he can do that
he did that with the man gog in marvel
comics and the man that's what it looks
like
just four villains of all time and
because the man gog is basically the
population of an entire planet into one
just monster so like yeah odin is crazy
so which is like like a messed up mind
like like a cronenberg mind
what also is uh is
more interesting though about odin is
that he that's all without mjolnir
with mjolnir he actually has like new
things that he can do um like he can
actually obviously he can enchant
millionaire itself so you know with his
his odin force magic he's like able to
like adjust what the powers are and the
rules of it but uh he can like
think and then like send meow near to a
place specifically like a uber eats car
or something like just put a little
lunch on it and just like send it over
to mt
um
obviously the different enchantments uh
there's somebody else who could do is he
oh he can um possess somebody's body
if like they like go if they're like
adjacent to me or something either way
he can like possess people if he uses
the power of mjolnir so like not just
read their thoughts but then like take
over
so obviously like this is like one of
the longest lists we've ever had of just
people's powers
they're gods bro
that's how intense this this has been so
i know we have we're still more to go
trying to figure out who's more powerful
but
before we get into who would win in a uh
a youtube style boxing match let's give
a shout out to the place i am yes the
epic hero merch
the headquarters that he's in epic hero
shop amazing shirts over at new
rockstarsmerch.com our latest obsession
shirt cosmic daydream inspired by miss
marvel is here and it's not gonna last
forever i designed that one oh yes it's
very good i love it um i need to get one
myself it's really great um you don't
have one now get them for free i know
what
there are so many i'm behind actually a
couple shirts i've been meaning to talk
to zach but i was like exactly on
vacation
jack's on leave i'm at the headquarters
right now i'm just gonna i'm just gonna
grab you so people can see that i'm
wearing short shorts email me the shirts
i'm getting you i'm getting you this one
this one
yeah this little girl yeah yeah epic
little girl or whatever
that's the one i wanted the most
this little uh
eric boss doll
there you go exactly that's all for you
i'm taking that stuff
to you
rockstarsmerch.com has all that and more
just for you so you do not miss out
especially on our latest decision shirt
inspired by miss marvel over at new
rockstarsmerch.com today it's amazing
stuff reminder that uh on that one if
you do get the latest obsession shirt
you get to uh leave a shout out on
inside marvel and then uh eric has to
uh tattoo whatever you say on his body
where are we going we're trying to put
these two uh against each other yes so
my friend who is the stronger of the two
they are generally thought to be about
equal and considering their incredibly
similar strengths and resistances you
can definitely see why they're often put
on the same level but there are some key
points that make us think that odin is
the one who will win in a fight between
odin and zeus
it's gonna get complicated but
zeus has fought
and
thor is definitely like not capable of
defeating zeus but the thing is zeus
like thor actually kept up
and like keeping up at all odin is way
more powerful than thor and the fact
that like thor was not just immediately
decimated kind of does show that at the
least him and uh odin and zeus are like
evenly matched but that odin would
theoretically be more powerful he also
zeus he does kind of like the [ __ ] move
but like he's ended fights in a truce
you know just kind of like oh really now
that your nose is bloody you want to be
friends again you know like truce man
he's ended fights kind of earlier we
don't really see quite how far um he
goes and then thor and odin have fought
a bunch of times like any good father
and son and every time odin just like
spanks thor like completely destroyed
like way worse than uh the way that zeus
was like kind of dealing with with thor
but also that's true right it's like
your family members that can like hurt
you the most so unclear on that but the
fact that they that that little triad
there
would imply that odin could
theoretically whoop zeus it just makes
sense i feel like that's just logic
reasoning but another reason odin would
probably win is his age and for a
variety of reasons of course with age
comes experience and the billions of
years that odin has on zeus means that
he's had more fighting experience and
the ability to own his craft and become
a master tactician i am older i am wiser
do not mess with me that's why you never
fight an old man
don't do it have you seen taken have you
seen several you know how many fights
those old men have been in
so many have you seen the expendables
all of them old
yes exactly yeah
don't mess with old men in fact when the
sky fathers were planning to fight
against the celestials they unanimously
chose odin to be their representative in
addition to all this the god's power
weakens with every generation and odin
is the son of boer one of the most
powerful gods ever and inherited his
powers from him
yes and then there's also like i don't i
don't know much about this but i know
that there's uh this like the serpent
that that is a um character that is like
on uh thor and odin
fight at times uh odin defeated the
serpent the serpent is like insanely
powerful it's a
sky father level uh being and odin did
that before having the odin force
so now
even it's like
zeus is at that level and that now odin
has the odin force so i would argue
we are declaring here total conclusion
yes
because he's older and wiser
anthony hopkins could beat the [ __ ] out
of russell crowe yeah we're saying that
right now it's official pay-per-view
though next week we'll find out for sure
five five five five five five oh my god
yes i think that just makes a lot of
sense the all-father odin would just be
the one to like take down zeus if you
just look at zeus in the thor loving
thunder trailers that dude's just
chilling he's not in no position he
hasn't fought in years i just feel like
he's just like all right and like odin
he's he stays fighting he's like i'm
ready to fight today well not anymore
he's dead but like before he died he was
he was always ready to scrap so odin for
sure fur damn sure all right it's been
decided it's been declared yes
hey play that clip uh uh just cause it's
my favorite one of uh uh odin whispering
the uh hey little shorty thing what
happened to uh
[Music]
just just play that
that's how we know he went he wins yes
but now it is time for our box of scraps
built into the cave of the box
[Music]
now my friend i've got a question for
you what's the question would you rather
be an olympian or an asgardian
why
an olympian or an asgardian okay
so
my gut oh man it's tough because it's
kind of like the olympians are more
famous hey
i want to be famous
right definitely so it like comes with
like a lot of fame like individually
like we know their names
versus like there's so many asgardians
um that you know it's not like it's
particularly special to be an asgardian
you're not special especially just the
word asgardian too because like there's
kind of levels within asgardian so it's
just like maybe you're like a lame as
cardiac
powers
or whatever
but i so i want to say olympian for that
reason
but the the weird thing is like
i don't know like
i like that that
okay
olympians are like known to get kind of
like wild and like a little kinky and
weird
but they kind of like way overshoot it
they'll be like hey you see that goat
over there i had sex with it and now i
have babies that are like
conquering
uh grease which is like
okay that was a little little you you
went a little too far as guardians
meanwhile yeah like valkyrie and thor
and all these people you can tell they
just like like they hang they party and
they like just have like a really good
life but they don't also like do weird
[ __ ] like i disguised myself to be an
old stone and then i made love to that
other goat and now we have stone goats
please stop just all right
they did like too weird of things yeah
the olympians are really sketchy
sometimes exactly i would be an
asgardian because it's like me when i
was like 23 years old or so like it's
like just out of college you think
you're invincible but you still
drink and like you know have like party
time or whatever but you're just like
rain you're have you have free reign to
do anything and there are no laws that
apply to you
nobody likes 23 because you can do
literally anything
and that's what that song meant i would
have to agree with you because uh
asgardians is the way to go i just feel
like you know i just read too much like
bad things about olympian gods in uh
well growing up in the elementary school
they just there's so much drama with the
titans and all that stuff i'm just like
ah i don't want to deal with zeus and
his weird
weird fetishes and like all this stuff
so i'm just like i'd rather be an
asgardian even though loki would
probably i don't know put a laxative in
my coffee or whatever like i would deal
with that yeah but that's
that's fun right like he's like he's not
like putting a a laxative in you and
then he and then make you go like
the goats they're just the goats are not
safe
with the other kids
away from there i like that your initial
thing was there's just too much drama in
olympia
like you're kind of right though like
enough where those are the most ancient
stories that have lasted the longest
time exactly
weird dramas with each other like they
invented drama
also like something we didn't really
acknowledge this episode but it's kind
of like they're pretty down with incest
you know like it's just like
a thing
yeah like again goats so
now that said
a goat brother and a goat sister must
never mate
[Music]
that's when we crossed the line but yeah
let me add that goat
speaking of the go speaking of the goat
it's been a pleasure to do an episode of
big question with you mtv oh my god
you're my favorite today no thank you
philip for joining me i'm like it's so
great to actually do videos like i would
love to do more please come back we love
you on big questions in general invite
me back yeah yes follow phillip at
philip molina he's amazing he tweets
amazing things you can follow me at
mastertainment you can follow new
rockstars wherever we are on the
internet when you do on youtube make
sure you hit that notification bell so
you can get notifications every time we
upload a video and if you want to
continue the new rockstars conversation
on our discord search for new rockstars
on discord or you can just click the
link in the description to join us but
you got to be 18 years old older because
we talk about really fun adult stuff
over there sometimes and you got to make
sure that you're an adult too but
anyways we love you guys uh thank you
guys so much for watching and we'll see
you guys next time bye
bye bye bye we love you horny goats
[Music]
you